[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
numéro spécial du set it culture
consacré au festival dvd deluxe tous
iront à la rencontre d'auteurs et de
passionnés et nous vous présenterons
également les différentes animations
mais avant cela voici le sommaire
c'est la 28e édition du festival de bd
au château de buc au programme des
rencontres avec des auteurs et des
dédicaces nous rencontrerons le créateur
du festival de nombreuses animations
sont aussi proposées durant les deux
jours de festival cette année encore les
visiteurs pourront bénéficier de
caricatures en live et puis enfin des
ateliers pour enfants hors du château
sont organisées la ville de vire au fait
a accueilli le dessinateur de yakari
xavier giacometti
[Musique]
je me trouve en compagnie de jean-luc
mirman bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
créateur du festival c'est ça c'est la
28e édition à cette année alors
normalement on ne présente plus le
festival de bd mais pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas est ce que vous pouvez
me rappeler ce qu'est le festival de bd
big alors le festival de bande dessinée
de buc c'est une manifestation annuelle
qui
réunit un certain nombre d'auteurs nous
avons commencé à dix auteurs puis 15
puis 20 puis 30 puis 50 quand il n'ya
pas de pain béni voilà cinquante auteurs
est en principe ils sont tous là font et
ce à quatre auteurs de bandes dessinées
qui viennent
dessinateur pour la plupart qui viennent
dédicacer leurs ouvrages de l'année où
deux d'anciens ouvrages pour un public
sans cesse plus nombreux et bien sûr et
j'espère pour vous et justement vous
l'avais dit en plus d'une cinquantaine
d'auteurs sont présents ce festival
c'est vraiment un moment d échange entre
le public et les dessinateurs finalement
devait absolument absolument nous ne
sommes pas des skis des esclavagistes
l'auteur il n'est pas tenu de faire tout
tout les deux journées est devant le
public mais tout se passe très bien dans
ce sens que
l'organisation est là pour dire l'auteur
de des cases telle heure à telle heure
et en principe tout le monde s'en sort à
merveille tout le public en tout cas et
quant aux auteurs y reviennent chaque
année ce qu'on invite nous disent oui
donc vraiment oui et j'ajoute que ce
sont des auteurs de premier plan pour
certains d'entre eux oui bien sûr et
d'ailleurs bientôt les 30 ans du
festival nous y pensons nous y passons
nous avons dans la tête la fiche du 29e
mais surtout la fiche du 30e également
et nous vous promettant des surprises
merveilleuse soyez persuadé c'est
vraiment devenu finalement 1 un
événement incontournable de la ville de
vue que vous l'avez vu vous même vous
avez vu le monde qui est qu avait ce
matin à cause de la présence je pense la
présence tout à fait exceptionnel 2 du
merveilleux de l'immense roireau
guarnido hauteur de blacksad qui qui
nous a dit avec ait accepté notre
invitation et je vais vous dire la même
chose fondamentale que le public et
ignorent c'est que nous le panneau
depuis plusieurs années il était déjà
venu il ya 10 ou 15 ans mais là cette
année en étant 2021 un jour j'ai reçu
nous avons reçu un mail de roireau pour
nous dire oh les jeunes ma nouveautés et
pour la semaine d'avant but je peux
venir le dimanche c'est vous voilà dieu
existe
justement vous parlez de royan guarnido
y en a plein d'autres est ce que vous
pouvez me donner peut-être en deux trois
coups de coeur mais l'auteur louis je
vais vous les donnez tout naturellement
nos anciens se dire herman herman qui
les tours du bon maury ou bien via duke
ou bien comme hanche qui vient chaque
année depuis après année où devenu il
est revenu chaque année ce qui se plaît
à buc ensuite il ya l'immense dany dan
nica fait olivier à hanoi qui a fait
tant les temps de jolies choses et qui
je crois nous prépare peut-être spiro
pendant quelques plaquettes que moi et
qui est ce qu'on a encore eh bien nous
avons pour la première fois en 28 ans
nous avons réussi à faire venir un
dessinateur des schtroumpfs 1 voilà vous
savez que l'auteur les schtroumpfs est
décédé maintenant il ya 30 ans et sous
le copyright bio voilà donc on a un
certain nombre de dessinateurs qui
peuvent venir en tout cas c'est la
première fois que nous avons réussi à
faire déplacer un auteur des schtroumpfs
c'est une jubilation super merci
beaucoup jean luc myre monde à voir avec
plaisir célia merci et puis bon alors
pour étouffer la liste voici d'autres
auteurs également présents sur ces
festivals
[Musique]
oh
j'aime bien bu qu'un franchement non
versées un bel établissement c'est un
parks et puis apparemment d'un lectorat
pas mal surpris cette année ci
[Musique]
le festival de bd de but est donc le
rendez vous des passionnés vous en avez
rencontré quelques-uns regarder des
passionnés venus parfois de loin pendant
ces deux jours de rassemblement le
traditionnel festival de bd de bucca
fait de nombreux heureux parmi les fans
j'ai eu aussi une bd des schtroumpfs de
laurent cagniat qui est un on va dire il
travaille pour les studio peyo donc ce
sont des élèves de peyo qui reprennent
le dessin et qui doit vraiment suis
vraiment les traits de peyo sinon j'ai
eu des auteurs espagnols et italiens
qui sont très difficiles à avoir dans
mon pays en belgique s'ils ne viennent
pas souvent et même ici en france ils
viennent pas très souvent non plus j'ai
attendu pour avoir une très belle
dédicace du dessinateur qui s'appelle
alex macho et du coloriste s'appelle
gare luc aggir j'ai un client fidèle du
festival depuis de nombreuses années et
c'est très bien organisé et quand on
demande aux amateurs la bd est souvent
une passion issus du plus jeune âge je
pense que c'est une passion déjà qui
remonte à l'enfance et
dans la bande dessinée il ya la fois le
le dessin bien entendu le scénario est
en fait le fait que la bande dessinée
soit un petit peu un art hybride entre
la littérature le théâtre le cinéma un
festival occasions même pour les fans de
découvrir de nouveaux auteurs moi je le
connaissais pas j'ai l'élu en forme
mesure et j'ai beaucoup aimé les
l'histoire finalement et ben voila je
n'ai acheté
et je les fait dédicacer une opportunité
unique d'échangé et repartir avec des
dédicaces qui ne passe pas inaperçu
fresque caricature ou encore espaces
pour enfants pour cette 28e édition le
festival propose de nombreuses
animations nous y sommes partis en
renfort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
atelier manga coloriage ou encore
origami de nombreuses animations pour
les enfants était proposée lors du
festival de bd de but ben moi je les
découpe des personnages puis l'école
dans les cages pour cela une bd un autre
je porte pour la salle de bain comme ça
on sait si elle est invitée qui
connaissent pas encore chez nous si ou
la salle de bains où la chambre
fait là bas j'ai dessiné obélix j'écris
saluer par la spirale mais des
animations en tout cas pour créer ça ça
sa page de bd j'ai vu qu'il y avait
aussi un peu d'origami un peu de
coloriage enfin bon différents thèmes
qui sont pas pas trop mal
[Musique]
et
au rez-de-chaussée une fresque a été
réalisée par l'atelier croc-en-jambe
collectif d'auteurs de bd spécialisée
dans l'animation d'ateliers ils ont
dessiné durant les deux jours du
festival
l'idée de la presse était de reprendre
la fiche en fait de cette année du salon
et d'imaginer la case d'après don quand
même personnage de barbe rouge qui
étaient tournés vers en fait vers les
spectateurs et de se demander qu'est ce
qui pouvait bien voir avec un bateau
échoué au fond donc on l'a repris en
mode un peu par audi et donc
khobar brouchon retournant voie sur
laquelle d'après qui a le garagiste en
train de faire le constat du bateau qui
a échoué autre animation des caricatures
en live l'artiste doom et en réalise
depuis quatre ans pour le festival donc
le but c'est d'en faire à la fin le plus
possible mais le plus fantaisiste
possible aussi et donc donc sa destinée
au public et à la tête burlesque
rigolote charmante enfin mon toutes
sortes de selon les visages et je les
plombs dans des situations les plus les
plus cocasses possible ça peut être
comme je disais ce matin une dan qui est
en train de ces peluches etc et dans une
banane en fait qui sait plus tout seul
bon c'est voir des choses comme ça des
salades de fruits gelé gens qui sont
plongés dans des verres des des amoureux
qui se croisent les orteils dans une
baignoire enfin c'est vraiment sans les
mises pour ulysse la caricature était un
garçon bodybuildé c'est moi mes muscles
c'est un peu mais ça me fait drôle mais
c'est marrant quoi
voir comme ça des conférences sur
l'auteur edgar jacobs étaient également
organisées tout au long du week-end
autre que le festival au château de vue
des ateliers ont été organisés dans
d'autres villes bien sûr en lien avec la
bd comme à viroflay pour l'auteur et
réalisateur la ville jacques comédie est
venu transmettre sa passion aux enfants
si ce qui fait la puissance de la bd à
la bibliothèque de viroflay une
vingtaine d'enfants ont assisté à un
atelier bd et cinéma présentée par le
dessinateur et réalisateur de yakari
depuis 17 ans xavier qui a committee
chaque année la bibliothèque d'office de
girofle à un partenariat avec le
festival de bd de buc et donc on reçoit
un dessinateur ou un scénariste bd qui
propose en a tenu pour les plus jeunes
plutôt à l'aise avec l'univers de la bd
les enfants de 7 à 12 ans connaissait
tous yakari je lis yakari
je lis aussi tentants c'est très bien et
nous expliquer comment passer d'un d'une
bd en film après la bd nous expliquer
des croquis les différentes étapes de
coloriage c'était bien j'ai bien aimé
comment il expliqué et comment savoir
comment était fait des films comment
procéder faire la bd oui
objectif de cet après midi là pour le
réalisateur montrer l'envers du décor
les enfants gardent beaucoup de dessins
animés peut-être certains lisent
beaucoup de bandes dessinées mais il ya
un aspect que les enfants ne connaissent
pas c'est le tout le l'aspect un peu
cuisine fabrication secrets de
fabrication et et ça c'est intéressant
le partager je remonterai pas des choses
on rigole voilà donc quand on regarde
certaines images que j'ai eus montrer
qu'ils sont des choses qui est nous
l'autre quotidien dans le travail et qui
est la réalité de ce métier là ils ont
quand même été je pense qu'il va leur en
restait quelque chose le film yakari la
grande aventure sera projeté en
ouverture du festival de bd de but
vendredi 8 octobre à 20h30 au théâtre
des arcades de but en présence de xavier
giacometti et c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale au festival de bd de
l'udc merci de nous avoir suivis rendez
vous la semaine prochaine dans un autre
lieu culturel évinois bonne soirée sur
tv5
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]